hey guys how are you so I'm off to San
Francisco I'm so far behind on vlogs
that I could potentially have posted
that I was in Ohio or Chicago or London
or somewhere I'm not really sure pretty
much given up hope of actually staying
on top of posting things on time I
apologize but either way I'm heading to
San Francisco and I'm really excited
because he more just goes one of my
favorite cities the food is so good that
people are so awesome and I don't know
it makes me happy every time I go there
so I'm excited to go and visit I'm gonna
be speaking on a panel with a bunch of
people in the gaming industry so we're
going to the game marketing summit let's
go get on a plane I just need to get to
the airport as fast as I can because I
need a coffee oh my gosh so I'm here you
two were checking out that are your
building this is awesome so you can
select your video experience I would
like to go to the California coast I
just assumed it was touchscreen and it
was holy moly my video will begin and
okay it's emergency stop I almost hit
the button
holy crap it's moving okay that actually
scared me look at you
whoa what is happening
short progress that was my show oh hi
back from San Francisco I filmed pretty
much nothing actually at all
so back in Los Angeles about to get a
haircut
and then I'm going to something tonight
I'm not sure it's the Microsoft lounge
it's for the Silicon Valley show which
I'm really behind I watched like the
first season I put the show's hilarious
so I'll go yeah this hair I was like
looking at myself in them in the
reflection it's a mess my car is a mess
my life is slightly in shambles to be
honest with you I I'm not sure how to
fix it okay let's start with a haircut
maybe that'll solve everything
hi Jen hello so in my video I just came
for my haircut which I just got what do
you guys think it looks very it was very
fresh i jus wanna cut an inch but then
we ended up cutting like a little more
than two cuz it really needed it and it
was either I cut a little bit or I cut
all of it off which you've been thinking
it I need to get a haircut who do then
are we at today John we are at the
Microsoft Lumia event which he's Silicon
Valley cast it's funny cuz I in this
video I just came from San Francisco so
it's like okay
more welcome to the event system thank
you I'm really excited it's funny
because I have spent a lot of time in
San Francisco and watching the first
season it was a very accurate very
accurate depiction of it was ever just
go yeah I mean it's a little bit over
the top but it's quite something I
actually film it in San Francisco I
don't think so I think they film but
here okay well we're gonna get a drink
and Jenna's gonna probably give me a
little score on her new little phone and
look at you you are so Microsoft swag
now right now hi I'm to leave now but we
have to play
gentle with my favorite game